aws cloud development kit is an open
source tool that allows developers to
use their favorite programming languages
to write infrastructurous code for aws
matt martz is an aws community builder
and he will teach you how to use the aws
cloud development kit hey i'm matt martz
and i'm veronica martz and i'm an aws
community builder and i'm 5
and i'm here to give you a cdk crash
course
from free code camp
you might be here because you're tired
of manually provisioning your resources
via the console
or maybe like me you hate writing yaml
but cdk has also been in the news a lot
lately
in december version 2 became generally
available
version 2 was a massive improvement over
version 1 since there is only one stable
npm library to install instead of one
for each module
among other improvements
cdk was also featured fairly prominently
in dr vogel's reinvent keynote
and the cdk book was released
the cdk book was written by a bunch of
aws heroes and it'll go into greater
depth than what will be covered in this
crash course
there will be overlap but i still
strongly recommend the book
so what will we cover in this course
i'm going to start by going over the
basics of cdk
definitions of the app stacks constructs
how it all relates to cloud formation
then i'm going to do a 30ish minute
speed run of the cdk workshop which is a
workshop provided by aws and it's
available at
cdkworkshop.com from there we'll go into
some advanced topics like testing and
best practices
this course is split up into chapters on
youtube so if there are particular areas
of interest feel free to jump around
i'll also provide time-stamped links in
the description with supplemental
information
this will include useful documentation
blogs links or anything else
i'm going to go through the cdk workshop
very quickly but you should do it
yourself
the best way to learn about cdk is by
using it
and
since this is a youtube video feel free
to speed me up
slow me down or re-watch sections if you
need to
if you think i missed something in this
crash course or you didn't understand
something let me know in the comments or
follow me on twitter and reach out there
i'll be happy to help
[Music]
here are a few other resources i'd like
to specifically call out
the cdk community on slack is very
active it's full of friendly
knowledgeable people that love to help
out
the authors of the cdk book are also
very active there
speaking of did you hear there's a cdk
book out now
aside from that there's also cdk day
which is an annual conference related to
cdk
last year i gave a 15-minute lightning
talk on creating verifiable jots with
cdk and i'll add a link to that below
and with that out of the way i hope
you're in the right place
let's move on to the basics
cdk stands for cloud development kit
it's open source software provided by
aws that enables you to write imperative
code to generate declarative cloud
formation templates
it enables you to define the how so that
you can get the what
that means you can focus more on the
architecture of your app instead of the
nitty-gritty details of iam roles and
policy statements
cdk is available in javascript
typescript python java c-sharp and it's
in a developer preview for go
cdk itself is node.js-based even if you
use one of the other languages the cdk
code itself will be executed via node.js
so node.js is a requirement
okay so cdk generates cloudformation but
what's that
cloudformation is an aws service that
provisions aws resources and stacks
aws resources are things like lambda
functions s3 buckets dynamodb tables
pretty much anything that aws offers
a cloud formation stack is just a
collection of aws resources
cloudformation uses json or gml files as
a template that describes the intended
state of all the resources you need to
deploy your application
the stack implements and manages the
group of resources outlined in your
template
and it allows the state and dependencies
of those resources to be managed
together
when you update a cloudformation
template it creates a change set
a change set is a preview of changes
that will be executed by stack
operations to create
update or remove resources so that the
template becomes in sync
so cdk generates cloudformation and
cloudformation provisions aws resources
what does the cdk app look like and how
does it relate
the root of cdk is the cdk app
it's a construct that coordinates the
lifecycle of the stacks within it
there is no cloud formation equivalent
for an app
within the app you can have multiple cdk
stacks and cdk stacks can even have
nested stacks
cdk stacks are one-to-one equivalent
with cloudformation stacks and nested
stacks are also one-to-one
equivalent with cloudformation stacks
when you run cdk synth or cdk deploy
the output is the cloudformation
template for this app structure
the cdk app is a special root construct
that orchestrates the life cycle of the
stacks and the resources within it
the app lifecycle constructs the tree of
the app in a top-down approach and then
it executes the methods for the
constructs within it
you typically don't need to directly
interface with any of the prepare
validate or synthesize methods of the
constructs but they can be overridden
the final stage of the app's lifecycle
is the deploy phase where the
cloudformation artifact is uploaded to
cloudformation
the unit of deployment in cdk is called
a stack
all resources defined within the scope
of a stack either directly or indirectly
are provisioned as a single unit
cdk stacks have the same limitations as
cloudformation stacks
stacks are powerful
in cloudformation in order to deploy a
template to multiple environments you
need to use cloudformation parameters
but these are only resolved during
deployment
in cloud formation if you want to
conditionally include a resource based
on a parameter you have to use the
cloudformation condition
but in cdk you don't have to use either
you can simply use an if statement to
check a value whether the resource
should be defined or not
it ends up being much simpler
you can use cloudformation parameters
and conditions in cdk
but they're discouraged since they only
resolve during deployment which is well
after cdk synthesis
we've heard a lot about constructs but
what are they
there are four levels of constructs
level 0 constructs are just basic
resources
all of the higher levels inherit from
level 0 there's no specific type tied to
it
level 1 constructs are one-to-one
representations of cloudformation
resources
they are all prefixed in the cdk api
with the letters cfn which is a short
form of cloud formation
the way i remember this is level one is
one-to-one with cloudformation
level two constructs are improved or
extended level one constructs
they're provided by the cdk team and
offer helper methods and sensible
defaults
level three constructs are combinations
of constructs
which could be an intermingling of level
one two and three constructs together
more often than not you'll be
interacting with level two or three
constructs
some modules in cdk don't have level two
constructs yet but pretty much all of
the level 1 constructs exist for the
corresponding cloudformation api
the cdk team is very fast at
implementing changes to level 1
constructs and more frequently used
level 2 constructs
for a level 1 construct let's look at
the access analyzer module
in this case the module doesn't have any
level 2 constructs available so there's
only the level 1 cfn analyzer construct
as you can see this is a one-to-one
representation with the cloudformation
api
the cfn analyzer construct has the same
properties defined as the cloudformation
api for the same
there are also no helper or utility
methods on the cfn analyzer construct
for a level 2 construct let's look at
the dynamodb table construct it doesn't
have a cfn prefix and includes many
sensible defaults
for example
the billing mode defaults to pay per
request unless you specify replication
regions
if you specify replication regions it
becomes provisioned
and if it becomes provisioned the
default read and write capacities get
set and defaulted to 5.
the default removal policy of the table
is retained
and
the table has helper methods to create
global or local secondary indexes and to
create varying levels of access to the
table and its streams
for level 3 constructs the cdk doesn't
offer anything specific out of the box
these tend to be created at the
individual organization or community
level and provided as libraries
an example level 3 construct would be to
create a notifying bucket
this construct creates an s3 bucket
along with an sns topic
it then adds an object created
notification coming from the s3 bucket
to target the sns topic
all you have to do to use this is add a
new notifying bucket to your app and it
will provision all of these resources
automatically
there are several great resources in the
community that i'd also like to call out
cdkpatterns.com is a resource that
enables you to search by community
provided examples and it's
cross-referenced by the different
components used within it
aws also offers another open source
extension of cdk with their aws
solutions constructs
these provide multi-service
well-architected patterns for quickly
defining solutions in code for
frequently used patterns
this is available as an npm library that
you can install and use right out of the
box
there's also the construct hub
the construct hub is a central
destination for discovering and sharing
cloud application design patterns and
reference architectures designed for cdk
cdk for kubernetes and cdk for terraform
and other construct based tools
construct hub pulls from the npm
registry all cdk constructs that support
multiple languages and are correctly
annotated
so i think we have a handle on
constructs now let's go a little deeper
how do we generate the cloudformation
template
in order to do that the app needs to be
synthesized
to do this we can run cdk synth
this traverses the app tree and invokes
synthesize on all of the constructs
this ends up generating unique ids for
the cloudformation resources and
generates the respective yaml along with
any assets that are needed
okay
so what are assets
assets are the files bundled into cdk
apps
they include things like the lambda
handler code docker images layer
versions
files going into an s3 bucket etc
they can represent any artifact that the
app needs
when you run cdk synth or deploy these
get output to a cdk.out
folder on your local machine
okay so
what does cdk do with these assets how
do they get put into cloudformation
well that's where bootstrapping comes
into play
bootstrapping creates a cdk toolkit
cloudformation stack deployed to your
account
this account includes an s3 bucket and
various permissions that are needed for
cdk to do the deployments and upload the
assets
bootstrapping is required when your app
has assets or your cloudformation
templates become larger than 50
kilobytes
so it's pretty much always required
you're almost always going to have some
sort of asset in your stack
for cdk version 2 administrator access
is needed to create the roles that cdk
toolkit stack needs in order to do
deployments you won't need administrator
access after cdk is bootstrapped
with the bootstrapping done we can move
on to deploying
when you run cdk deploy the app is
initialized or constructed into an app
tree
once the construction is done the app
goes through preparation validation and
synthesize steps
so
each construct calls its prepare method
then each construct calls its validate
method and then each construct calls its
synthesize method
up to this point this is what cdk synth
does
from there the app uploads the template
and any other artifacts to cloud
formation
and cloudformation deployment begins
once this handoff is done it's all in
the hands of cloudformation
now that we've defined some of the basic
pieces of cdk let's move on to the
workshop the workshops at
cdkworkshop.com
you should do this first and then come
back
perfect once you come back we'll do the
30 minute speed run through the workshop
we're going to get started with this
workshop by creating a cloud9
environment to do that i'm going to
steal some instructions from the cdk
pipelines workshop
it's going to have us create an im role
for cloud9 that has full access this is
going to be used in bootstrapping the
account for cdk version 2.
links for the cdk pipelines workshop
will be in the description below
it's a great workshop and you should
work through it if you have the time
first we're going to go to the cloud9
console and create an environment
i'm just going to name it cdkworkshop
and we don't need a description
then we select an instance type i did
this workshop with a t3 small instance
but the m5 large would probably be
better
all the other options can use the
defaults
while cloud9 spins up i want to note
that both the t3 small and m5 large
instances are not free tier eligible so
it might cost you some money
i was getting some memory errors towards
the end with the t3 small instance but
it still worked
to create the iam role
the cdk pipelines workshop has a deep
link that will take you to the role
creation page
from there we confirm that it's aws
service entity and for ec2
and then go to permissions
make sure that administrator access is
selected
we don't need any tags so we can skip
that
and then we're going to give it a name
we're going to name this cdk admin
and create the role
with the role created we can go back to
the cdk pipeline workshop and see that
we need to actually go in and attach the
roll to the ec2 instance
there is a deep link but since we named
the ec2 instance something else we
actually need to go to the ec2 console
go to instances
and then select the instance that with
our cloud9 instance that's running
go to actions
security
and modify iam role
from here we're going to select the ian
rule that we just created cdk admin
and save it
now if we go to the cdk workshop cloud 9
and refresh
it will automatically have the role that
we need
next we need to do some cloud 9
housekeeping and setup
we're going to remove the aws managed
temporary credentials these prevent us
from using the role that we attach to
the cloud 9 ec2 instance
in the upper right corner of cloud9 go
to settings
and then scroll down to aws settings
and turn off aws manage temporary
credentials
to make doubly sure that the credentials
are gone we're going to remove the
credentials folder
next we're going to do some environment
config
we need to install jq using yum
and then we're going to export some
environment variables with aws account
information
to check to make sure that the aws
region was set correctly we're going to
do this test command
and finally we're going to export the
account id and region and make sure aws
is configured correctly
now we need to make sure that cloud9's
ec2 instance is using the write a iam
role
to do that we're going to use this sts
get caller identity command
it's going to fail here because we
actually named the rule cdk admin so if
we update the command to check for cdk
admin
we'll get the that the iam role is valid
like this
at this point we can switch back to the
actual cdk intro workshop
we're gonna go to the prerequisites tab
and start checking things to make sure
that everything is
like it should be
the aws cli is already installed and
we've already set up the aws account in
user
next we want to make sure that we have a
good node version installed in cloud9
cloud9 comes with node installed so
let's just check the version
and here version 16 is fine
we're also going to want to check cdk
now this is a cdk2 workshop so we want
to make sure that we actually bump up
the version of cdk so if we do
npm i for install aws cdk
globally we're going to get this error
because
he's the cloud9 instance of ec2 is weird
so you actually have to force it in this
case the cdk pipeline tutorial also goes
through this as well
now that we've force installed it we can
see that version 2.3 is installed
we're already using aws cloud9
we just checked the cdk version
and that concludes the prerequisites
next we can begin the actual workshop
so let's get started we'll go to the cdk
init step
the first thing we need to do is create
a director to work in so we're going to
make the cdk workshop directory
and change into it
now we need to actually init the project
so we're going to run cdk init sample
app with the language typescript
this creates a git repo and npm installs
all the dependencies for a basic
cdk2 project
cdk2 is a massive improvement over cdk
version 1 because it bakes in all of the
stable modules into one npm dependency
cdk version 1 had individual nbm
libraries for each module like dynamodb
lambda sns etc
in version 2 you just have one and that
avoids a lot of the dependency
management hell
now that the project is initialized the
cdk workshop is going to want us to run
the watch command of the background to
compile the typescript into javascript
so we're going to create a new terminal
change directories into the project
folder
and then run the npm run watch command
in the background
with that done
we can move on to the next step and
actually check out the project structure
of what was what's been initialized so
far
so let's go back to the cloud9
environment
we'll open up the
project folder and let's start looking
at some files
let's start where cdk starts with the
bin cdk workshop typescript file
this file instantiates the cdk app by
creating stacks that is to say when you
run cdk synth or cdk boy it starts here
to generate the cloud formation
templates
cdk stacks are one-to-one equivalent
with cloudformation stacks
an app can have multiple stacks and each
stack would end up creating a new stack
in cloudformation
in the case of our sample app there's
only one stack the cdk workshop stack so
let's look at that next
the sample stack is pretty simple it
uses two level two constructs
one to create an sqs queue and one to
create an sns topic
then subscribes the queue to the topic
that's it
the workshop goes into similar detail
with these
but let's move on to our first cdk synth
as described before when cdk apps are
executed they produce an aws
cloudformation template for each stack
defined in the app switching back to
cloud 9 let's run cdk synth i'm going to
output to a template.yaml file to make
it a little easier to read
now there are two important concepts i
want to call out here
cdk is both imperative it describes the
how the app will be built but it's also
idempotent given the same inputs it will
produce the same outputs
see here
we use the same code between the cdk
workshop in my cloud9 instance
and the cloud formation that was
generated is the same
for example the resource hashes match
between the two
this is because we used all the same
inputs that the cdk workshop did
if i went and changed the topic or queue
id the hash would change and we'd have
something else this is going to be
important in unit testing later
now that we've synced let's deploy
in order to do that we need to bootstrap
the account
let's open up a new console window and
go to cloudformation
in this account the only one running
right now should be the one that's used
for cloud9
right here
so let's go back to the cloud9 terminal
and run the bootstrap
this is why we need to create an iam
role with administrator access and it's
actually the only time you need admin
access when you're bootstrapping the
account
in order for cdk to deploy apps it needs
to store the assets somewhere
the bootstrap creates its own
cloudformation template that we'll see
when we go back to cloudformation
and that includes a number of roles and
policies that enable it to store assets
for deployment
as you can see here the cdk toolkit
stack was just created from the
bootstrap process
now
if we switch back to cloud9
we can actually run the deploy command
the deploy command
re-synthesizes the app
and if there's any iam policy changes
from the stances it will display them
and ask to make sure that you want to
continue
here
since we're subscribing the
cue to the topic
a
i am policy needs to be in place in
order to make that happen
so yeah we do want that to happen so
let's deploy it
while cloud formation is spinning up if
we refresh cloudformation we'll see the
cdk workshop stack create is in progress
and we can actually view the resources
as they're created
so here we can see that there's a
metadata entry along with the queue and
topic but there's no actual subscription
yet or policies related to it
now that the creates complete we can go
back to the resources and see
that yes there is a queue policy
and a subscription
well that was fun
but now let's get our hands dirty
the cdk workshop is going to take you
through a couple steps at this point
we're going to clean up the stack by
removing the sms topic and the sqsq
and then we're going to create a simple
api gateway backed by a lambda
so let's get started we're going to
delete the sample code from our stack
and then we're going to do a diff to see
what it shows
go back to the stack file
and delete the
queue topic and the topic.add
subscription along with the imports
then we'll run the cdkdiff command
what cdk diff does is it re-synthesizes
the cloudformation app
and compares the yaml from one to the
other and we can see here
that it's destroying the q q policy
subscription and the topic
next we can cdk deploy
as it's deploying
the only thing that the cloudformation
stack should be left with is the cdk
metadata entry
so we go back to cloudformation
we can check the progress of this by
refreshing the resources as it
is progressing
there done
now let's go back to cloud9 and create
the lambda
we'll create a folder called
lambda
and put a hello.js file in it
inside of that we'll put some basic
lambda code
next we need to create the lambda in the
stack
we'll add the lambda import from cdk2
and then
create the actual lambda function
one of the biggest benefits of creating
aws resources using cdk is the
intellisense having imported from aws
lambda i can create a new function using
new lambda dot function
pass the stack and id of the lambda in
and give it some properties
in this case we need to define the
runtime
using lambda
dot runtime.node.js runtime.node.js14
where the code lives
which we use code dot from asset
and then lambda which uploads the
lambda folder as an asset to s3
and then where the handler is
in this case our handler is in hello the
hello file and it's named handler
now we can run the diff
and this will show us that it's going to
create a i am role for the lambda and
the lambda function itself
which this looks good to me so let's
just deploy it
i'm gonna speed this part up a little
bit
and done
we can see the function and the role in
cloudformation
so let's test out the lambda itself
in the code source area of the lambda
console we can create a test event by
clicking the test button
we'll select api gateway aws proxy
because ultimately we'll be connecting
this to an api gateway
don't forget to give it a name
and it
doesn't like spaces
and hit create
when we hit test again it'll invoke the
lambda
and now we can see the status of 200
and that the body has the correct
response
so let's add an api gateway
first we'll import the api gateway
module from cdk
and then we'll create a lambda rest api
lambda apis are
just rest apis with a greedy proxy that
sends everything to the defined lambda
we'll pass in the stack construct and
give the rest api an id
and then we'll tell it our hello
function as the api handler
now we can run a diff
and i'll also show that there's actually
no api gateway already defined
by going to
the api gateway console
and here there's no apis
so let's deploy it
i'm going to speed this up again but
what it's doing is it's creating a bunch
of resources automatically there's the
api gateway itself permissions for the
gateway and for it to invoke the lambda
etc etc
now that it's done
we can see we went from three resources
to 15 in cloudformation and this was all
handled with a couple lines of code
and if i go and refresh the lambda page
we can see that the api gateway is added
to the lambda console as a trigger
similar we can see the api is defined on
the api gateway console
so let's test it
we'll grab the api url that was
automatically output
as part of the deploy
and send it a curl request
nice
and let's try another one
very nice
all we've done so far is use a few level
2 constructs
let's make our own level 3 construct
we'll make an interceptor lambda that
writes to dynamodb table and then
invokes any targeted downstream lambda
let's get started
we'll create a new hit counter
typescript file
in the lib folder
and put some boilerplate construct code
in here all this does is extend the
construct and define the props
next let's create our interceptor lambda
in the lambda folder we'll create
hitcounter.js
and we'll copy the code over from the
workshop
what this code does is it uses two
modules from the aws sdk to interact
with both dynamodb and lambda
we'll use update item from dynamodb to
increment a hit counter for a path and
we'll use the lambda client to invoke
the downstream lambda and then return
the response from that lambda
both the table and lambda will be passed
into this interceptor lambda via
environment variables
[Music]
now that that's done we need to create
both the table and the lambda
we'll add the dynmodb module from cdk
and then create the table
using new
dynamodb dot table
we'll pass in the stack construct and
give the table an id
and dynamodb also needs to define a
partition key so we'll go ahead and
do that as well
next we'll create the lambda this
follows the same pattern as before
new lambda.function
pass in this
give it a id
and set the
runtime which is node.js
the handler
which in this case is
hit counter dot handler
and then
the code
coming from code.fromasset lambda
[Music]
we need to pass in the environment
variables
and i'll make a tweak to the lambda id
just to be consistent with the workshop
now we're going to want to expose the
lambda as a read-only property of the
construct
so add this public read-only
aligned to the class
and we'll assign the lambda to the
property
now this construct is great as is but
it's not being used anywhere so let's
fix that
we'll go back to the main workshop stack
and use the construct
it's the same pattern as a level 2
construct
so we can do new hit counter pass in
the stack
give it an id
and in our case the properties here is
the downstream lambda that we want to
invoke so we'll set downstream to hello
and i will do a trick to import the hit
counter from the local file
but now we need to make the api use this
lambda instead so we will move the api
below
and change the handler of the api from
hello to hello with counter
and this is why we exposed the read-only
property for the handler it's so that
the api actually has access to the
lambda within the construct
so let's deploy it
with some editing magic we'll skip ahead
again
now that we're deployed we can test it
the cdk workshop builds in some errors
to expose some nice things about l2
constructs
as we can see the request here failed in
order to see why we'll need to look at
the logs so let's switch to the lambda
cons in the console
click the monitor tab
and click
view logs in cloudwatch
[Music]
if we go to the latest log stream
we can see
that there's an invoke error and it's
because of an access denied exception
and if you read a little further it says
basically that the lambda is not
authorized to perform dynamodb update
item on the resource
we never gave it permission
so let's go back to the hit counter file
we're going to use the tables l2
construct helper method of grant read
write data
to apply the correct policy statements
to lambda
the workshop also forgot to add the
permission for the lambda to be able to
invoke the downstream lambda so we're
just going to go ahead and add that now
now if we deploy again
and skip forward
and we test the function
we'll get a successful response because
everything has the correct permissions
[Music]
from here if we go to dynamodb and
refresh the items in the table we can
see that the right endpoints are being
tracked
from the cdk workshop we're going to
npm install
the cdk dynamo table viewer library into
our project
with it installed
we can switch to our stack
and
import the table viewer
from the library
then we're going to go and create a new
instance of it
this table viewer library is an l3
construct because it groups multiple l2
constructs together just like we did
with the hit counter l3 construct that
we made in the previous section
the table viewer construct expects us to
pass in the dynamodb table from our
other construct
but we didn't expose that so let's go
back to our construct
add the table
property
and assign the table to that property
with that we can pass the hello with
counter dot table property into our
third party construct
now if we deploy
and skip ahead
we'll see that the table viewer
construct created a separate api gateway
and its own endpoint defined in the
outputs
if we go there
it will end up displaying what's in the
dynmo db table
testing constructs is one of the most
powerful things about cdk
the cdk workshop walks you through two
types of tests
assertion tests and validation tests
for the first assertion test we're going
to create a stack and use our hit
counter construct
and then
verify that one dynamodb table was
created
so let's go back to the code
create the test
and remove the old ones
now we can run it
and one dynamodb table was created
next we'll move on to checking the
lambda the cdk assertions library has
some useful features like capture which
can intercept different properties as
part of the template synthesis
in this case we'll use capture to verify
that the correct downstream function and
table names are being passed into the
hit counter lambda
when we run this test we expect it to
fail because i didn't copy the
references from the synthesized output
but making it fail actually makes it
easier to find them
so we'll grab the correct names
and update the test with right ones
now when we run it
it'll pass
next let's switch to a test development
mindset and say we want to make sure our
table is using server-side encryption we
can assert that dynamodb table resource
has server-side encryption enabled so
when we run the test
it'll fail
from a development perspective that
means we need to go back to the
construct
and make sure that server-side
encryption is enabled
and now if we run the test again
it'll pass
since we don't actually want that i'm
going to remove it from the construct
and remove the test
next let's talk about validation testing
let's say as part of your construct you
want to make sure a same number of read
capacity units are being used in the
dynamodb table
[Music]
we can add a read capacity property that
gets passed into the construct
use it in the table
and then in the constructor we can
validate that the value passed in is
reasonable say between 5 and 20. if it's
not we'll throw an error
now let's add a test that passes in a
value out of range
say 3. and verify that the error is
thrown
when we run the test
it'll pass because the error is being
thrown
this arrow would be thrown as part of
stack synthesis so let's see that
we'll go back to our workshop stack
add an out of bounds read capacity value
and run the stack synthesis
as you can see the error is thrown
validation testing is super useful at my
work i use it to help enforce some
naming conventions
and also to log or throw deprecation
warnings when property inputs or
defaults change
great job with the workshop
now that the workshop's done we can move
on to some advanced topics like aspects
and best practices
in the workshop we went over
fine-grained assertions by checking for
things like
number of tables created and ensuring
encryption was turned on
we're checking to make sure the lambda
environment variables being passed in or
the right one
but you could also use snapshot testing
to check the entire template if you
wanted to and use just's match snapshot
functionality
we also went over validation testing as
part of the workshop
we checked the properties being passed
into the construct to make sure read
capacity units were within a specific
range
in my organization we also use this to
help enforce some naming conventions as
well as throw some deprecation warnings
in the event we have to significantly
change the construct
in this case the warnings won't block
deployment but it will show up in the
console when doing synth or deploy where
developers can pick them up and fix them
you aren't limited to just logging
errors to the console though
when you synth you're executing the
actual code so you could also log to an
external service like a platform service
that tracks deployments or log to cloud
watch itself
the last form of testing is integration
testing
with cdk you can use aws custom
resources to test that the resources are
working together correctly as part of
the cloud formation deployment
if something breaks it will
automatically roll back the
cloudformation deployment
cdk has a provider framework for
interfacing with cloudformation custom
resources
these custom resources enable you to
write custom provisioning logic and
templates that cloudformation runs
anytime you create update or delete
stacks
we can make use of this to do
integration testing across our stack
let's say you have an event bus a lambda
and a dynamo db table that you want to
make sure are interacting with each
other
you could use the provider framework to
spin up a lambda to emit a test event on
an event bus
all part of the cloudformation
deployment and then the custom resource
can query dynamodb waiting for the
change
if the change doesn't happen in a set
amount of time
the build will fail and cloudformation
will automatically roll back the changes
matt morgan has an excellent blog post
about this called testing the async
cloud with aws cdk
the cdk book also has a section on this
another advanced topic for the cdk are
aspects
aspects are a very powerful tool in cdk
they're a way to apply an operation to
all constructs in a given scope
the aspect could modify the constructs
such as by adding tags or it could
verify something about the state of the
constructs such as ensuring that all the
buckets are encrypted
during the prepare phase cdk calls the
visit method of the object for the
construct and each of its children in a
top-down order
the visit method is free to change
anything in the construct
in this example the bucket version
checking class implements a visit method
that checks if s3 bucket versioning is
enabled
here it throws an error but you could
just as easily modify the construct to
enable versioning
everything that the stack is applied to
that is every construct within the stack
is evaluated by this visit method
which is why we need to check the
instance of the node being evaluated to
make sure it's the cfn bucket
the nodes will all end up being the
level one construct of the resource in
question even if you used a level two
bucket construct within your stack code
for best practices aws breaks up their
best practice recommendations into four
different areas
organization coding
construct
and application
for organization best practices aws
recommends having a team of cdk experts
help set standards and train or mentor
developers in the use of cdk
this doesn't have to be a large team it
could be as small as one or two people
or it could be a center of excellence if
you have a large organization
aws also recommends the practice of
deploying to multiple aws accounts for
example having separate production qa
and development accounts
you should use continuous integration
and continuous deployment tools like cdk
pipelines for deploying beyond
development accounts
for coding best practices
aws recommends to only add complexity
where you actually need it
don't architect for all possible
scenarios up front
so to keep it simple stupid principle
it also recommends to use the well
architected framework
aws cdk apps are a mechanism to codify
and deliver well-architected best
practices
as you follow these principles
you can create and share components that
implement
them earlier i stated it's possible to
have multiple apps in a project which is
true
but it's not recommended
a best practice is to not do that and to
only have a single app per repo
in a cicd world changes to one app could
unnecessarily trigger the deployment of
another app even if it didn't change
finally your cdk code and the code that
implements your runtime logic should be
in the same package
they don't need to live in separate
repositories or packages
for construct best practices
you should be building constructs of
your logical units of code
if you consistently build websites with
s3 buckets api gateways and lambdas
make that a construct and then use the
construct in your stack
it's a bad practice to use environment
variable lookups within your constructs
environment variable lookups should
happen at the top level of a cdk app and
then be passed to the stacks and
constructs as properties
by using environment variable lookups
and constructs you lose portability and
make your constructs harder to reuse
if you avoid network lookups during
synthesis and model all your production
stages in code you can run a full suite
of unit tests at build time consistently
in all environments
be careful how you refactor your code
that may result in changes to the
logical id
the logical id is derived from the id
you specify when you instantiate a
construct and the construct's position
in the app tree
changing the logical idea of a resource
results in the resource being replaced
with a new one at the next deployment
which you almost never want
constructs are great but they're not
built to enforce compliance
compliance is better suited to using
service control policies and permission
boundaries
for application best practices make your
decisions at synthesis time
don't use cloud formation conditions and
parameters
for example a common cdk practice of
iterating over a list instantiating a
construct for each
isn't possible using cloudformation
expressions
treat cloud formation as an
implementation detail and not a language
target
you're not writing cloud formation
templates you're writing code that
happens to generate them
if you leave out resource names cdk will
generate them for you and it'll do so in
a way that won't cause problems when you
end up refactoring your code later
cdk does its best to keep you from
losing data by defaulting to policies
that retain everything you create
but cloudwatch is expensive
go through and set your own retention
policies
cdk also has helper methods that will
empty an s3 bucket using a custom
resource prior to destroying a stack
which is very useful
consider keeping stateful resources like
databases in a separate stack from
stateless resources
you can turn on termination protection
for stateful stacks while keeping it off
for stateless ones
stateful resources are more sensitive to
construct renaming which is another
reason to keep them in a separate stack
it reduces risk when reorganizing your
app later
determinism is key to successful cdk
deployments
cdk context is a mechanism for recording
a snapshot of the non-deterministic
values coming from synthesis
this allows future synthesis operation
to produce the same exact template
non-deterministic values result in using
things like a constructs from lookup
where you're looking up an external
resource
these from lookup values are cached in
cdk.context.json
the grant convenience methods allow you
to greatly simplify the iam process
manually defining roles or using
predefined rules in your aws account
causes a big loss in flexibility in how
you design your applications
service control policies and permission
boundaries are better alternatives to
predefined roles
another cdk best practice is to create a
stack for each environment
when you synthesize your application the
cloud assembly created in the cdk.out
folder contains a separate template for
each environment
your entire build is deterministic
most of the level 2 constructs in cdk
have convenience methods to help in the
creation of metrics which you can easily
use to generate cloud watch dashboards
and alarms use them
[Music]
finally there are a few more resources
that i'd like to call out
free codecamp has a great blog post
about how to use cdk version 2 to create
a three-tier serverless application
i have several posts on my blog related
to cdk but one in particular shows how
much using a general purpose programming
language enables you to extend the cdk
even further
in my open api specs from cdk without
deploying first article
i show how you can traverse an api
gateway's endpoint structure during
synthesis to output an open api spec
first without deploying
lastly serverless stack framework is
pretty neat
it extends the cdk and enables local
lambda development
it has a pretty neat console for
observability when doing development too
definitely worth checking out
if you made it this far through the
lesson thanks for watching
thanks
you can follow me on twitter at
markzcodes and my other socials and my
blog posts are located at march.codes
this was a free code camp
cdk crash course
thanks bye
bye